[Musique]
en 2020 avec la pandémie de covile 19
les nouvelles d'afrique ont été rares
dans les médias le monde ne pensait coco
vide et il y avait en afrique
considérablement moins de cas qu en
europe mais quelque chose mérite est
néanmoins qu'on y prête attention
les médias ont annoncé un boom des
naissances chez les éléphants au kenya
les journalistes y ont vu un lien avec
le fait que les touristes n'étaient pas
autorisés à entrer dans le parc ils ont
aussi vu un côté positif au confinement
mais en réalité le qu'ovide n'avait rien
à voir avec ce phénomène
[Musique]
la période de gestation chez eux dure 22
mois en 2018 vous comprenez nous avons
eu de très fortes pluies et les femelles
sont excédentaires
alors en 2020 nous avons eu ce baby boom
de 106 et les fantômes
d'importantes intempéries
cela veut dire que les femelles ont plus
de nourriture à donner aux éléphanteaux
des choses vraiment extraordinaire se
passe dans le parc national d'amboseli
la femelle patia a accouché de deux
jumeaux
ce qui est extrêmement rare
[Musique]
c'est une mère très très intelligente la
grand-mère est ici la mère de patients
elle s'appelle peuvent pas
parfois nous voyons les éléphanteaux
restera coté du marais avec la
grand-mère alors que patia va manger
dans le marais
ensuite elle revient vers ses enfants et
la grand mère va dans le marais s'ils
sont gros c'est qu'ils sont en bonne
santé ils sont en excellente forme
les enfants sont en forme parce que la
mère et la grand-mère prennent soin
d'eux
[Musique]
quand les mâles auront grandi ils
quitteront la famille et les femelles
resteront ensemble les pères ne
participe à la vie de leur progéniture
ils vivent de leur côté et ne revienne à
la maison que pour l'accouplement il
n'est même pas toujours possible de
savoir qui est le père c'est la plus
vieille femelle puis veille sur la
famille elle sait où se trouve l'eau et
les meilleurs pâturages
en ces temps de coheed la vie des
éléphants n'a pas changé
les éléphants n'ont pas remarqué qu'il y
avait une épidémie de covin mais il
pourrait se demander pourquoi n'y at il
plus de touristes et plus de voitures je
pense qu'il demanderait sa s'il pouvait
parler
[Musique]
mais pour ceux qui travaillent dans le
parc où habite à côté
les choses ont radicalement changé
en ce moment beaucoup de gens sont
renvoyés chez eux limogés dans beaucoup
d'entreprises j'ai entendu parler du cas
d'un chauffeur qui avait un très gros
crédit il a fini par se suicider
peter saitoti et mécanicien il habite
près du parc national d'amboseli même
s'ils ne travaillent pas dans le parc
lui-même sa famille en dépend
directement
avant je pouvais réparer les motos des
gens pendant qu'il faisait leur cours
mais maintenant ils ne peuvent pas venir
donc les magasins et nous autres
mécaniciens en souffrons au cas
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas peur des prédateurs
j'ai grandi ici donc je sais où il ne
faut pas aller nous avons nos chemins
ils ont les leurs
quant au vide c'est loin de nous on ne
l'a pas encore vu ici à berlin pas
nous avons les maladies habituel mais
pas de kovy telle personne d'entre nous
ici n'est mort du co vide mais je sais
qu'il existe un
aujourd'hui nous n'avons aucun moyen de
gagner notre vie certaines personnes
n'ont pas de nourriture nous n'avons pas
de travail nous n'avons rien nous
commençons à nous inquiéter parce que
s'il n'y a pas de touristes il n'y a pas
de travail
[Musique]
même si cela ne fait pas partie des
statistiques mondiales sur le co vide le
virus a eu un impact sur la vie de
presque toutes les familles kenya
je m'appelle rosa home à
35 ans
le vide est arrivé la situation s'est
détériorée un coaching on avait de
l'argent seulement pour se nourrir
nous avons tous eu peur pour nos
salaires surtout les femmes de ménage le
coc vide a beaucoup changé ma vie elle
est devenue bien plus difficile
les clients ont peur de nous laisser
entrer dans leur maison et ne nous donne
que de petites tâches j'ai commencé à
gagner beaucoup moins ils ont arrêté de
payer des sommes convenable bâlois a
couvert
tout dépend de moi maintenant les même
si je ne gagne pas d'argent dont nous
allons nous coucher affamés
[Musique]
des femmes enceintes venez chez moi me
posais des questions sur leur grossesse
je regardais leur ventre leur disais
comment se portait les foetus en
fonction de la forme du ventre certaines
femmes ne pouvais pas dormir
parce que le foetus n'est pas dans la
bonne position et je règle est le
problème
[Musique]
je peux prédire le moment de
l'accouchement selon la taille du ventre
je mets simplement la main sur le ventre
et définit la date de naissance du bébé
à mettre au monde des bébés depuis ma
jeunesse
combien de femmes avez vous reçu depuis
le début de la pandémie une selle j'ai
refusé toutes les autres pourquoi il y à
une épidémie on nous a dit de ne pas se
toucher les uns les autres
j'ai peur de contracter la maladie elles
ont peur des infirmières et nous d'elle
quad idée mais je sais que j'ai une
santé fragile si j'attrape le colis de
gens mouraient tout de suite
[Musique]
j'en suis à mon septième mois de
grossesse à
bozouls de manière générale les femmes
enceintes n'ont pas de chance unique et
necib se retrouver dans une telle
situation en ces temps si difficiles
j'ai du mal à me pencher et a soulevé
des choses qu'on aimait avant les gens
s'arrêtaient pour aider maintenant les
gens passent leur chemin
désormais tout le monde a des problèmes
mais pas pour
les business les médecins les marchands
même l'environnement
le coc vide nous a vraiment gâcher la
vie
[Musique]
vous ne pouvez même pas vous imaginer ce
que c'est d'être enceinte maintenant et
nord
[Musique]
j'ai un autre enfant de 5 ans
avant mon frère nous donner de l'argent
il prenait soin de nous
ils nous apporter à manger par exemple
mais maintenant c'est fini il a sa
propre famille son entreprise a fermé
maintenant je me débrouille tout seul
le petit a toujours besoin de quelque
chose par exemple s'il a besoin de ça
bon je lui en achète
wallace il a besoin de vêtements je lui
en achète
il a besoin de beaucoup de choses bien
sûr c'est difficile
[Musique]
mais j'ai peur de ne pas pouvoir revenir
au travail après l'accouchement
si je ne peux pas je ne sais même pas
il faut toujours payer pour quelque
chose et je ne gagne presque rien en ce
moment l'argent ne pousse pas sur les
arbres bas salaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'une des rares personnes qui a su
trouver une solution face à ces
nouvelles conditions et lincoln ndiogou
qui dirige une école privée
[Musique]
je dirais que lorsque le coc vide nous a
frappés au mois de mars ça a été le cas
au total réponse
[Musique]
j'ai appelé tous mes professeurs
mais dès ce 15 2 nous avons eu une
discussion
je leur ai demandé qu'est ce que nous
pouvons faire avec cette somme pour
assurer votre subsistance puisque
l'école ne pourra pas vous payer sont
donc nous avons décidé ensemble que la
meilleure chose à faire est la moins
chère c'était d'élever des poules
donc nous avons commencé avec 700 dans
ces classes sauf un seul goal com nous
avons pas mal gagné et avons pu non
seulement payer un salaire à nos
professeurs ou dinan pépite chasse mais
aussi investir les bénéfices dans le lot
suivant
et là soudain classe on a appris que les
4e et 8e années allait rouvrir à nouveau
c'était un autre grand défi parce que
les enfants allaient retourner dans les
salles où les poulettes est élevé
nous avons donc dû déménager dans une
pièce plus large dans le réfectoire nous
avons cette fois me 1200 poule
et nous avons commencé à repeindre des
classes
grâce aux derniers lots nous avons un
fonds de roulement pour construire une
nouvelle école la nex njima canini c'est
une nouvelle institution que nous avons
bâti ici
et dans cette mésaventure nous avons
ouvert cette annexe nous avons cent
dix-huit nouveaux élèves on commence
on avait commencé avec 5 et maintenant
ils sont plus de 700 places donc on peut
dire qu'on a réussi à s'en sortir en
effet espèces
presque 200 mille personnes ont été
infectées par le col vide au kenya soit
0,3 pour cent de la population
les scientifiques expliquent ce chiffre
par le fait que l'âge moyen sur le
continent et de 20 ans les personnes de
plus de 65 ans ne représentent que 3% de
la population
j'espère seulement que nous reviendrons
à une vie normale que les touristes
reviendront il n'y en a plus au moins
quelques touristes et que les gens
puissent revenir au travail donc
j'espère que nous reviendrons à une vie
normale
[Musique]
le kenya a rouvert ses frontières comme
la plupart des pays africains
[Musique]
mais les touristes restent toujours très
peu nombreux
[Musique]